I think it's about time we tried
building Cat Clicker again, but
this time we have better
organizational skills.
You'll be doing the same
project we ended with before.
The application shows a list of cats
that when you click on one of them
it updates the cat detail area
with the clicked cat's details.
Now the primary thing you need
to remember is to separate out
the view entirely from the model.
Use an octopus for communication
between the two, never do it directly.
Personally, I would
build it with two views.
One for the cat list and
the other for the cat detail view,
each with their own render methods.
And remember to never have the model and
view talk directly to each other.
That's very, very important.
Once you're done, I'll show you my
model of the octopus implementation.
Here's the spec sheet for
Cat Clicker Premium.
Go forth and build it.